Софії Громаковій 16 років. Війна забрала її дім - Маріуполь
і батька, який його захищав.
Я пам'ятаю, я в цей час, звичайно, я намагалася йому щось сказати:
"Тато, будь ласка, не йди". Але я пам'ятаю,
що він казав, що "Доцю, я обіцяю, я повернуся, все буде добре".
Рідний Маріуполь і Азовське море залишилися у спогадах
і на картинах. Творчість допомагає Софії впоратися з тим,
що довелося пережити після 24 лютого.
24 лютого, я пам'ятаю, я навіть не брала телефон у руки.
Я заварюю чай, вже починаю його пити,
підіймаю жалюзі на кухні, а я жила на п'ятому поверсі.
І тут я щось бачу, що щось там світиться, блимає.
Я думаю, так, а що коїться?
Я відкриваю телефон, дивлюсь новини.
Усі шоковані, не знають, що робити.
І тоді вже мій тато, бо він військовий,
був, 25 років вислуги, він сказав, нічого не робимо,
нікуди не їдемо поки що.
Вже тоді було дуже мало бензину на заправках,
були величезні черги.
28 лютого тато Софії - Андрій - пішов у тероборону.
Дівчина з мамою залишалися вдома,
поки у двір не почали прилітати снаряди.
За температури мінус шість надворі довелося перебиратися
в гараж у іншому районі міста.
Ми з мамою вийшли на вулицю, горять автівки
поряд з нами, догорають якісь снаряди,
горять дерева, все горить.
Потім ми спускаємось у підвал гаража,
спимо десь ніч на скатках, просто на шинах,
вкриваємося старими килимами, ми чуємо,
як вилітають снаряди, як вони летять, як вони приземляються.
І от у цей час, я пам'ятаю свій стан,
це була одна велика суцільна істерика, бо ти не розумієш,
що тобі робити, ти не розумієш, як себе поводити,
бо це може бути реально остання ніч.
Софія з мамою залишалися в Маріуполі понад три тижні,
до 18 березня. Тато підвозив їм продукти й воду.
Холод, пошуки їжі, чорний дим з Азовсталі -
кожен день дівчина досі пам'ятає до найменших деталей.
Я пам'ятаю, яку я кашу їла.
Я пам'ятаю, що коли ми прийшли 7 березня додому,
що там лежала коробка сухофруктів від мого тата.
Ви не знаєте, де що купити, ви не знаєте, де воду взяти.
І ми пішли тоді до овочевого магазину,
і там я пам'ятаю, що в продавця не було решти,
і він віддав решту просто жменькою волоських горіхів.
Ми чуємо свист. Ми думаємо, що то летить снаряд, і, звісно, всі люди,
які чекають в черзі за водою, вони лягають.
То був літак, і моя мама каже: "Падай, падай, падай", а я не знаю, куди впасти.
Тобто повсюди якісь калюжі, я просто впала в калюжу, лицем туди.
Разом з випадковими знайомими Софії і її мамі
вдалося виїхати "зеленим коридором" з Маріуполя до Запоріжжя,
потім - до Польщі. Уже там вони дізналися,
що тато Софії загинув від прямого попадання російського танку
ще до їхнього від'їзду з Маріуполя.
11 березня я тоді з мамою була вже в порту.
Я пам'ятаю, я вийшла на вулицю, і я бачу, як він перекидає
мішки з картоплею через паркан.
І я була така щаслива його бачити.
І це був останній раз, коли я його бачила в своєму житті.
Мій тато пішов на війну, як він сам казав мені…
Він пішов просто, він навіть не вдягнув годинник.
Він в чому був, він в тому й пішов.
Він пішов, як і усі маріупольці, просто за свій дім.
Він казав мені, що я йду через те, що я не хочу, щоб тут була Росія.
Картини дівчини нині можна побачити в мерії Амстердама.
Історія Софії та ще 13 українських дітей представлені
на виставці проєкту "Щоденники війни".
Це спогади юних українців, закарбовані в нотатках,
малюнках, світлинах, особистих речах.
Музей Анни Франк розташований в Амстердамі,
її щоденник облетів весь світ 70 років тому.
Здавалося, що це неповторима історія, що цього вже не може бути.
Але тут наші діти у 21 столітті пишуть такі самі жахіття.
Згодом ця виставка приїде до Києва, а потім подорожуватиме столицями
європейських держав. Мета - аби голоси українських дітей почули у світі.
Ми батьки того покоління, які пишуть ті щоденники.
Ми народили те покоління, щоб воно будувало нашу Україну,
а зіштовхнулися з тим, що діти пишуть щоденники у яких
замість перших побачень, радості що вони закінчили школу,
опису своїх улюблених страв,
пишуть такі дикі жахіття. Яким ми бачимо це покоління?
Ми зробимо все, щоб це покоління справилося з бідою,
з якою зіштовхнулося, я маю надію, що я їх бачу в сильній,
незалежній і вільній державі, здоровими і продуктивними.
Софія Громакова кілька місяців прожила в Польщі і в Англії,
утім минулої зими повернулася в Україну.
Вступила до університету в Києві і поки саме тут бачить своє нове життя.
Припустимо, якщо в мене буде чоловік в майбутньому,
то він ніколи не зможе дізнатися про мене на усі 100%,
бо він не буде знати про моє дитинство.
Він не буде знати, в який я садок ходила,
бо його просто нема – був авіаудар.
Моя школа згоріла, її також нема.
Мої іграшки, їх також нема, жодної з них.
За даними Офісу генпрокурора, через повномасштабну
агресію Росії загинули щонайменше 500 українських дітей,
більше тисячі отримали поранення.
Ще тисячі маленьких українців носять у собі невидимі травми.
Софія з Маріуполя після всіх випробувань вірить,
що майбутнє її покоління буде іншим і кращим.
Однозначно українізованим повністю.
Це вже зараз пішло. Бо в мене, в Маріуполі,
українська вважалась якоюсь мовою села.
Ну, я так це бачила. Тобто люди, які розмовляли українською -
це було щось незвичне. Це висміювали люди.
І зараз я розумію, що я хочу перейти на українську.
Усвідомлено я намагаюся.
Я ходжу на заняття з української.
Я розумію, що наше майбутнє буде українізованим та повністю
ми будемо "кенселити" всю російську культуру.
І я дуже радію з цього приводу, бо я розумію,
що російське вбиває українське. Або вони тебе, або ти їх.